the Coen brothers once again going for
the Oscar we're here crew great True
Grit is the much-anticipated remake of
the John Wayne classic whether it has
the Duke or the dude still called True
Grit and it's the story of a little girl
named Mattie Ross who hires a couple of
guns to go on a manhunt to find Chaney
yeah no that would be Tom Chaney the guy
who killed her father and so the hunt is
on now I'm not gonna [ __ ] you with
Coen Brothers movies I kind of tread
carefully because they're well-written
well acted well directed and then the
ending happens and I always hate the
endings so like Alan Moore story's
well-written I love them then the ending
as consistent as gravity is always the
way it is until now actually I actually
enjoyed this movie throughout now we all
know that Jeff Bridges is a great actor
and in True Grit
yeah I'm not gonna lie he'll probably
get nominated for an Oscar again at
least he might even win I mean he was
badass he was memorable I'm telling you
if we had people like that today crime
rate would probably be down it's almost
like he has true grit Cogburn 2012 just
sayin and now I'm gonna straight-up give
the little girl in this movie props
Mattie Ross in this movie was a badass I
mean she was smart witty sarcastic and
clever almost to an absurd degree I mean
no kids are like that in real life that
I've met anyway it'd be awesome to see
one yeah she is that person and as a
sarcastic person myself who appreciates
that kind of thing I give her the
honorary awesome tacular award I mean
the title True Grit has just as much to
do with her as it does with Jeff Bridges
character the two are really unlikely
pair that they work and that Damon was
really good in the role and he does
offer his own perspective but in terms
of that bond for me it was all about
Mattie Ross and Cogburn and what I
really liked about True Grit is that it
felt real at a point I was like I am
really on a manhunt with these people I
mean it felt cold and miserable they
looked like they didn't want to be there
but the girl was like no I'm not leaving
until I have the brother from the
Goonies that is dedication
now I do wish she showed more of Josh
Brolin in the movie but in a movie like
this where someone's on a manhunt there
is something cool about the movie
staying with one party the entire time
and not showing you where the other
people are someone they're all like the
trails run cold I don't know what to do
you feel just as lost as them you're
like I don't know
well some people think this movie is
slow yes this isn't like high octane
Western it's not bounty hunting with
Boba Fett and Carbonite or anything like
that it is a very gritty and realistic
movie about a manhunt involving a little
girl a drunk in a metro Texas Ranger
which has very good dialogue as well
directed not half as artsy as I expected
it to be so I would say I would
definitely buy this movie even on
blu-ray
if not you would you live Nick Sean
beige I'm saving awesome tacular for the
movies that really hit me nowadays and
someone gets shot in this movie which is
easily one of my top ten moments of
someone getting blasted with a cult and
that ain't nothing I laugh does that
make me a bastard and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more
[Music]